Here today in Manhattan,
talking to Doctor Jonathan Heit who's a professor at Nyu.
And,
uh,
I'm here for a bunch of reasons.
Jonathan isn't extremely interesting researcher.
I've been following his work on disgust and political belief for literally,
literally for decades.
It was one of the first people who started to do serious research on disgust,
which is its own emotional system and therefore very much worth attending to.
Um,
but we also have some other interests in common.
Uh,
Jonathan also started this institute called the Heterodox Academy,
which is attempting to bring back a reasonable diversity of views,
what he regards as a reasonable diversity of views to university,
faculty and,
and campuses and discussion.
So,
um,
I first met Jonathan,
it's going to be just about 30 years ago,
25 years ago,
eight 2014,
yeah,
20.
I'm sorry,
the 1994.
Oh,
it was in 1994.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right,
right.
So yeah,
you came to do a job talk at Harvard too,
at for an assistant professorship position,
and I'd been aware of your work on discuss then and,
and agitated hard for them to hire you because I thought it was of great
significance,
which turned out to be exactly the case.
So what do you remember about that?
I remember I was so excited to have an interview at Harvard.
It was my only interview if I didn't get that job.
I had no job for the following year.
And it was a very strange day in which I didn't feel particularly welcome or
wanted.
And then I had my session with you in which he was this guy who was had,
he actually got a job at Harvard and he was studying young,
which is like almost taboo.
And he was talking about dreams and creativity.
And so I just,
that was the really bright,
that was the bright memory of the day was our hour long conversation.